computer how do I put the Joker in
Arkham Asylum quickest route no freeways
computer do you hear me hello master
Bruce I've just taken away your computer
privileges yes sir it's time for you to
stop this unhealthy behavior you can't
spend the rest of your life alone
dressed in black and staying up all
night for that Alfred sir
it's morning you need to take
responsibility for your life and it
starts by raising your son I'm sorry I
literally have no idea what you're
talking about
the young orphan you adopted at the
Ghana we rule I thought I was being
sarcastic
hello secret camera
it's the best oh my gosh oh my gosh oh
my gosh oh my god oh my gosh oh my gosh
head man whoa your time right whoa wait
does Batman live in Bruce Wayne's
basement no Bruce Wayne lives in
Batman's attic Wow look at a costume
don't touch that oh the Maurya she what
is culturally insistent a terror
really think of it glam bat this one
absolutely not wait what's that one
there I love it I only trouble is these
pants are just a little tight I got an
idea
rip it's better now I'm free now I'm
moving come on Batman let's get grooving
I can only look you in the eyes right
now are you ready to follow Batman and
maybe learn a few life lessons along the
way I sure AM but first where's the seat
belt the first lesson is life does it
give you seat belt
Oh Alfred I have incredible reflexes
Oh oh my goodness I am so sorry soon as
I get back to the Batcave I will make
sure that Alfred puts seatbelts on there
but for the time being I'm just gonna
put my arm right here and we're just
gonna gently he's out of here real
gentle like a computer I'm home what is
the password men in a minute and then a
Batman thank you I love it
I saved the city again today
I think you would have been really brown
there you are